consumers and important on both sides
the european union is already new
zealand's
third biggest trade partner
and with this agreement we should be
able to increase trade between the two
of us by 30 percent that's a big step
our farmers on both sides will benefit
and they will benefit way beyond tariff
cuts
because we will work together on
sustainable food systems we will work
together on animal welfare on food and
fertilizers on the reduction of
pesticides many many good topics
this agreement also protects 200
european agri-food products the called
famous geographical indications
eu investment in new zealand can grow by
80 percent and this is huge
and this is because we managed to ensure
a level playing field between eu
investors and new zealand and vice versa
new zealand investors and the european
union
we also managed to eliminate almost all
tariffs on eu exports to new zealand and
to improve access to our respective
government procurement markets
the agreement brings modern rules on
digital trade very important
so it facilitates the data flow between
us this is important but
it protects the individual rights so
protecting our values
it is a big step for our economies and
for the development of digital rules
internationally
but beyond economic benefits this
agreement has very important innovations
to bring just and green growth
it hits several firsts
for example it includes sanctionable
commitments to the paris climate
agreement
this is the very first time
that we take such commitments in a trade
deal the very first time
and it contains again for the first time
provisions on fossil fuels
this clearly reflects our common goal of
reducing fossil fuel subside subsidies
and reforming fossil fuel subsidies in
particular through the wto
and we show the same ambition on core
international labor standards
and on gender equality to advance
women's economic empowerment so this
agreement will bring major benefits
to our economies but also to our
societies
the second agreement we signed today is
on law enforcement cooperation
we just witnessed the signature of this
agreement for closer cooperation between
europol
and new zealand
this will strengthen significantly our
joint fight against organized crime and
terrorism
indeed both new zealand and the european
union have suffered heinous terror
attacks in recent years in church
willville in brussels in nice
this agreement will reinforce our
cooperation to help us prevent such
attacks
it will also address terrorist content
online
and it will guarantee high standards of
data protection
so the as in that these agreements come
at the right time the world needs
now very clear signals that democracies
like your hours
deliver for people
because the values we share
are challenged across the world
from ukraine to the indus pacific region
you're well aware of that
indeed russia's unprovoked invasion of
ukraine is sending shockwaves across the
world
it is driving food and energy prices up
it is endangering prospects for global
growth
and the lives and livelihoods of
millions it threatens the rules-based
order
so the democracies need to stand up and
stick together
and this is why the european union is
working
to strengthen its partnership with
like-minded partners and dear cinder of
course you are such a like-minded
partner
the agreements that we conclude today
are good for new zealand they are good
for the european union they are also
good for the global economy as a whole
and for our citizens and
they show that democracies are united
and that they are strong once again a
very warm welcome
well good afternoon and thank you
president wonderland thank you for the
welcome and thank you for the
conversation that we've just shared as
well and tina koto
today is an important day for new
zealand
and the european union including its 27
member states
this afternoon as part of a constructive
wide-ranging and warm discussion between
two good friends i'm delighted that new
zealand and the european commission can
announce that we have concluded
negotiations of a high-quality inclusive
free trade agreement
this is a positive outcome
both for new zealand
and for the eu
our relationship with the eu is
characterized by our shared values
as the president has said we are
principled driven democracies committed
to working together to build a more
sustainable future and to support the
international rules-based system and
we've embedded some of the important
principles that underpin these values
into this agreement
it is in our minds a model of how we can
create trade arrangements that support
our economies but also support people
and place
it's what we in new zealand call trade
for all
this free trade agreement has been some
14 years in the making
the concept of an fta was floated more
than a decade ago and it has been four
years since we started negotiating
our talks over the last two and a half
years have had the additional
complication of course of covered travel
constraints
but despite many challenges we got there
and today we deliver an agreement that
represents improved trade opportunities
for our exporters for small and large
businesses alike the agreement will
deliver real-world commercial benefits
at a time when our economies are
recovering from crovet and grappling
with the economic impacts and
instability of war
it contains groundbreaking commitments
as has been said by the president on
environment labor rights gender equality
as foundational parts of a trade and
sustainable development chapter and i'm
pleased that this fda also includes a
dedicated chapter on maori trade and
economic corporation which of course is
very important to aotearoa new zealand
if i were to tell you the story of this
ftin numbers it would read like this it
provides duty-free access for 97 of new
zealand's current exports to the eu 91
of those from day one
it grows the value of new zealand
exports to the eu by forecast 1.8
billion new zealand dollars per year by
2035.
and it provides enhanced access for new
zealand's world-class services exporters
into the eu market of around 450 million
people
and then there's what it represents for
our individual exporters kiwifruit is
finally able to come into europe
tariff-free previously it was hit with
eight percent tariffs and was forced to
compete with other producers who had
none
onions honey wine all have eliminated
tariffs and for dairy they finally have
conditions that will make it viable for
them to trade into this important market
ultimately this agreement creates new
opportunities it cuts costs and red tape
for our exporters in a hugely important
market and makes bold further steps for
sustainability
and while this is an incredibly
important day for our trade relationship
it's also a time to acknowledge the
extraordinary time and challenges that
europe is facing
new zealand and the european union are
united in our response to russia's
invasion of ukraine
we stand shoulder to shoulder with the
european union in condemning russia's
unprovoked and unjustified war of
aggression against ukraine
and we reaffirmed today our unwavering
support for ukraine's independence
sovereignty and
territorial integrity
we also emphasize the importance of
international efforts to ensure legal
accountability including for war crimes
and crimes against humanity with new
zealand planning to intervene on the
international criminal uh justice case
additionally we spoke about the close
coordination between new zealand and the
eu on the adoption of unprecedented
sanctions against russia and belarus we
confirmed our commitment to address
together with like-minded partners
russia's disinformation as well as the
global consequences of russia's
aggression against ukraine including
food and security
and of course i share the president's
enthusiasm for the fact that we have
been able to also today sign the europol
agreement which in these times is
incredibly important that we have those
information sharing arrangements that
also continue to underpin the values
that we have around uh privacy
protections that you would expect
between two like-minded countries but
enable us to further uh uh continue our
fight against uh international organized
crime and of course as you've indicated
the effects of terrorism
in closing and going back to the free
trade agreement because that is what
today will be remembered for the fta
conclusion marks a long awaited and
historic further milestone in the strong
partnership between two closely
connected like-minded friends i'm very
pleased to be here as part of this
historic moment
and to seeing what this free trade
agreement offers us as partners in the
future
thank you
thank you very much
let's wrap our stuff
yes
very good thanks a lot
[Music]
you